[Musique]
étranger
[Musique
] c'est une escroquerie
pour le public américain c'est une
honte pour notre pays
rires politiques
[Musique]
est
étranger
[Musique]
comment décririez-vous votre
affiliation politique euh conservateur conservateur
républicain I  Je suis un partisan républicain, je
dirais conservateur, mais réaliste,
je suis plutôt libertaire. Selon vous, quels
sont les grands problèmes pour les
élections de mi-mandat maintenant, comme vous le savez bien et
vous entendez de tout le monde l'économie, vous
connaissez beaucoup de gens qui  n'aime pas
Trump mais vous savez au moins quand le
président américain, vous savez qu'il y avait environ un dollar
prêt pour le gaz ici pour moi, la chose la plus
importante est la frontière,
je veux dire que vous faites venir des gens à la
frontière et je veux dire par millions mais
quelle que soit la frontière est probablement ma
plus grande, elle dure depuis le
plus longtemps, nous pourrions aussi bien commencer là-bas, je
veux dire que cela était en train d'être corrigé et
je continuais sans cesse et devenais de
pire en pire, je veux dire que chaque État
s'inv  ajouté maintenant l'
immigration
Donald Trump est que
je suis derrière Trump sur ce que je crois qu'il
y avait définitivement de la politique sale
il devait y avoir de la politique sale
pensez-vous que Trump était le vainqueur légitime
de l'élection
nous ne le saurons jamais vous ne savez pas  Je ne sais pas
personne ne sait tu sais tu
crois que l'élection a été volée
ouais
non non
mais tu as le droit de remettre en question je veux dire
j'ai remarqué que nous avons remis en question
l'élection de 2000 la 2004 la 2016. donc
nous avons le droit d'interroger ceux qu'ils
ont juste des camions de bulletins de vote qui
ont été livrés
par la porte arrière c'est juste des conneries je
veux dire que ces gens devraient être fusillés je
veux dire qu'ils devraient être punis et mis en
prison ils devraient être fusillés
directions électorales
étrangères
détruire
[  Musique]
Madame levit est que
je continue toujours d'être le seul
candidat dans cette course qui dit que je
crois que l'élection de 2020 a
sans aucun doute été volée au président Trump
Don Baldock
[Musique]
actuellement, je suis un étranger politique M.
Baldock al  véhicules défensifs viosi,
j'ai signé une lettre avec 120 autres
généraux et amiraux disant que Trump a
remporté les élections et bon sang, je soutiens
Miles
Davis
et j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches à ce sujet
et j'ai passé les deux dernières semaines à
parler à  Granite Staters partout dans l'
État de euh vous connaissez tous les partis et je
suis arrivé à la conclusion et je
veux être définitif sur ce point, l'élection
n'a pas été volée
[Music] l'
étranger a
vraiment utilisé pour s'entendre sur des choses comme
les marchés libres et la libre entreprise
libre-échange
um gouvernement limité baisse des impôts
c'étaient des thèmes unificateurs au sein du
parti républicain mais maintenant c'est devenu un
culte de la personnalité et il s'est
inversé sur des positions de longue date sur le
caprice de Donald Trump je trouve cela
personnellement profondément troublant et
inquiétant il n'y a pas
fraude électorale importante du tout, mais il y a des
gens qui y croient et suffisamment d'entre eux pour
que c'est maintenant une position que les gens
qui gagnent les primaires républicaines prennent l'
idée que personne ne peut  gagner une élection
légitimement est un vrai problème ces
jours-ci, alors maintenant, soit mon équipe a gagné, soit elle nous a
été volée et il n'y a pas d'
autres alternatives comme peut-être que l'
autre côté a obtenu plus de votes que votre côté
[Musique]
vous dites les gars du Massachusetts
étranger
[Musique]
Je pense que le président Trump
a fait
perdre cette élection injustement, je pense qu'il est
très juste de dire que l'élection a été
volée à Donald Trump, pensez-vous
que l'élection a été volée, c'est
que quelque chose qui est important pour vous les
gars en tant que  eh bien, je pense que ce qui
s'est vraiment passé cette fois-ci, c'est parce que
le grand public
a beaucoup insisté pour
que les
gens ne puissent pas savoir ce qui se
passait, je pense que fondamentalement, cette élection a
été corrompue par le euh le courrier lors du
scrutin, malheureusement, cela a donné beaucoup de
possibilités  pour les gens de remplir
les urnes essentiellement
pour beaucoup de républicains,
c'est devenu un article de foi,
c'est une question de dogme, vous ne pouvez pas
raisonner
à ce sujet la foi en  une élection volée est
devenue un proxy pour
souligner comment Trump
était contre l'élite régnante en
Amérique,
y compris les médias Elite étrangers
[Music
] c'est une
coïncidence
étrangère
[Applause]
[Music]
quel pourcentage des nouvelles grand public est
vrai
presque aucun je veux dire je je  J'aurais du mal à
croire que c'est même un pour cent
. Je pense qu'à ce stade, euh, les médias grand public
, j'avais l'habitude de penser que le renard avait beaucoup
de bonnes choses,
mais plus je
recherchais un certain nombre d'histoires, je trouvais
plus de preuves  que les choses opposées
où est-ce que vous recherchez toutes ces
informations où vous regardez simplement des vidéos
sur rumble ou bit shoot ou vous savez
qu'ils sont essentiellement des clones de YouTube euh
et vous rencontrerez juste des gens
qui partagent euh YouTube est à peu près
la boîte censurée et filtrée
va bien Newsmax va bien nous avons
beaucoup d'autres stations CBS NBC ABC
ils sont sur la tente libérale et CNN
je n'en ai pas besoin vous savez que j'en vois
assez à la télévision régulière je veux ha  j'ai une
station qui représente la plupart de mes opinions
pas tout le temps mais la plupart du temps
[Musique]
et que pensez-vous des
médias ici aux États-Unis comme
en général c'est horrible tous
c'est horrible ouais je regarde  Fox, je
regarde CNA, j'ai changé à travers chacun d'eux,
mais cela dépend de ce que votre parti vous
voulez, vous savez qu'il n'y a pas de parti pris et de
nouvelles en Amérique, il n'y a rien qui le
dit ouvertement comme ça
se passe aujourd'hui ça se passe
aujourd'hui cela se produit aujourd'hui que
ce soit à gauche ou à droite si cela s'est produit
aujourd'hui c'est une personne qui raconte un
côté de l'histoire et un côté qui raconte
l'histoire comment ils veulent la raconter
c'est plus comique pour moi que tout ce que
les
médias sont censés dire  être objectif juste et équilibré
les médias ont fait un travail affreux un travail épouvantable pour
protéger le président Biden beaucoup de
préjugés dans les médias américains vous savez à tous les
niveaux vous savez le papier journal télévisé vous nommez il
y a une différence entre un tsunami
et un  tremblement de terre un tsunami recule mais
un tremblement de terre change le paysage de
façon permanente et pour toujours et Trump était un
tremblement de terre politique les choses ne
vont pas remonter à 2012. La
politique américaine conventionnelle Barack Obama et Mitt
Romney ces jours sont révolus nous sommes passés
à quelque chose d'autre conduit dans  partie je
pense par les médias sociaux par le fait que les
gens peuvent avoir leur propre version des
nouvelles que les gens ont la leur nous ne pouvons même pas nous
mettre d'accord sur notre propre ensemble de faits les
choses ont changé en termes de
communication et comment les gens obtiennent des
informations je pense  il y avait cette
perception que les médias étaient devenus une
partie de la résistance entre guillemets à
Donald Trump ou du point de vue de la gauche
que les médias devraient faire
partie de la résistance
et je pense que certaines parties des médias ont adopté
ce point de vue à mon avis, vous savez
dans  à certains égards,
un peu cynique à moitié exact et vous
savez qu'il y avait beaucoup d'argent à gagner
en rendant compte de Donald Trump sur son
ascendant, puis en résistant à Donald
Tr  ump pendant sa présidence
[Musique] les
gens qui partagent toujours mes opinions ne sont peut-
être pas assez forts pour nommer des candidats
ou les aider à gagner des primaires, mais nous sommes
des électeurs dynamiques qui aident les candidats à remporter
les élections générales et je pense donc que
nous sommes assez nombreux
pour déterminer si démocrate  gagne ou
les victoires républicaines donc ce n'est pas si mal
ce n'est pas ça qui me fait me sentir
impuissant non plus
merci